the people who really inspire me are the
ones nobody knows the people who every
day in the worst situations in the world
still get up and try to hold life
together in war it's usually the women
you know let's face it even though some
militaries are incorporating women it's
generally men who wage war men who fight
wars and it's the women who are trying
to hold their families together you know
trying to keep the children safe they're
the people who make me you know on the
days that I feel like I don't want to be
a piece person anymore I just want to be
a normal like everybody else and I think
of those women and and really stop and
think if they can do it in those
circumstances I'm very privileged so I
get over myself and I get re-energized
by what they do and by some of the young
people that I have worked with over time